consider the following experiment you
have two pieces of metal copper and zinc
which you connect two conducting wires
and you then submerge the metals in an
electrolyte in this case vinegar you
will observe that bubbles will form
around the zinc but not on the copper
the metals seem dissimilar in this way
and if you then connect the two wires
holding the metals something changes
tiny bubbles begin to form around the
copper terminal it seems as though
something is being pulled from the zinc
through the wire allowing a reaction to
occur on the copper side and it turns
out this is a flow of electrical charge
as electrons are pulled away from the
zinc towards the copper through the
conductive path in the wire
[Music]
think of this blow as the result of a
charge imbalance or electrical pressure
between the two metals as compared to
the instantaneous discharge observed
with static electricity experiments and
towards the end of the 18th century
Alessandro Volta had been investigating
this effect more importantly he found
that chaining these cells together would
amplify this flow of charge and by 1800
he simplified things even further
removing the jar which provided more
electrolyte than was actually needed he
writes a few dozen small round disks of
copper pieces of coin for example and
equal number of plates of zinc I prepare
circular pieces of spongy matter capable
of retaining water I continue coupling a
plate of copper with one zinc and always
in the same order and interpose between
each of these couples a moistened disk
this continues until I have a column as
high as possible without danger of it
falling this is known famously as the
voltaic pile the first battery in
history to provide a continuous flow of
electrical charge or current more cells
resulted in an increased electrical
pressure at the two ends and electrical
pressure was an early term for what we
now call voltage after Volta now if the
two leads of a voltaic pile were brought
into direct contact a series of shocks
could be observed now at first the
utility of electric current as a
communication method was not immediately
obvious
aside from faint sparks and bubbles one
idea was to use the presence of bubbles
to signal letters and the bubble
Telegraph used this method though it
involved 26 different circuits one for
each letter and it was based on the fact
that the battery providing the current
can be placed at a distance away from
the jars containing the leads creating
the bubbles an inventive although clumsy
system which was never adopted
but very soon everything changed after a
famous demonstration in 1819 it was
found that if we simply pass a wire near
a compass and connect it to a battery as
soon as the wire made contact with the
battery the needle jumped without any
physical contact
the only explanation was that the
current carrying wire was creating a
temporary magnetic field this was
followed by a series of tasks to figure
out the direction of this field first we
assumed it was pointing along the wire
with the current or perhaps emanating
outwards from the wire as heat would
travel but eventually it was deduced
that it must be traveling around the
wire in perpendicular circles so a loop
of wire would create a magnetic field
which points through the center of the
loop and around the outside this led to
the galvanometer which was designed to
detect and measure electrical current
and it was just simply a coil of wire
with a compass suspended in the center
now when electric current was applied to
the coil
a magnetic field would push through the
middle of the coil and around the
outside so the needle would always point
perpendicular to the direction of the
force which was balanced on either side
of the needle and the stronger the
current the stronger the deflection of
the needle and by 1824 William sturgeon
demonstrated a way to increase the
strength of this field even more simply
by wrapping a coil of wire around a
piece of iron such as a nail the
magnetic force could be amplified
because iron seemed to be a better
medium for supporting the formation of
magnetic fields we call this
permeability and by wrapping the wire
many times the strength of the field
could be amplified thousands of times
and this is known as an electromagnet so
suddenly it was possible to create
magnetic fields which could move needles
with precision and force using electric
current applied at a distance using a
long loop of wire and a strong battery
at the time our understanding of
information was in its infancy people
were thinking about information and a
message as the number of letters in a
message so the goal was intuitive who
could come up with the fastest way to
transmit letters and whoever had the
fastest system would therefore reduce
the cost per message for the sender
using the system
and a goldmine was waiting for whoever
got there first
[Music]